[Musica]
[Applauso]
può partire il video
[Musica]
no
buongiorno a tutti io mi chiamo silvia
marangoni e pattino da quando tre anni
nella mia carriera ho vinto 11 titoli
del mondo e 12 titoli europei
e voi magari vi chiederete ti sei mai
adottata e questo di questo ve ne
parlerò oggi il 2013 fu per me un anno
fantastico l'anno più bello della mia
carriera ero arrivata a conquistare
dieci titoli del mondo ero arrivata la
stella era arrivata all'apice della mia
carriera e in un secondo
sono entrata nell incubo peggiore della
mia vita mi è successo un infortunio
possiamo cambiare la foto mi dovevo
preparare dovevo partire per
un'esibizione ero seduta e sono
cominciate dei dolori lancinanti al
petto alle braccia
ero seduta ho cercato di alzarmi in
piedi e le mie gambe non hanno risposto
sono caduta a terra
da lì la corsa in ospedale una tacca
d'urgenza e una dottoressa che esce si
avvicina e mi dice guarda un ernia
cervicale che non permette al midollo di
passare e quindi non puoi sentire le
gambe
l'unica domanda che fece questa
dottoressa fu posso continuare a
pattinare lei ridendo mi disse intanto
pensa a camminare che per pattinare c'è
tempo per me non c'era tempo perché in
quel momento
vedevo tutti i miei sogni sfumare vedevo
tutto andare in frantumi la mia passione
il mio grande amore il mio talento
non potevo più toccare non potevo più
pattinare non potevo più fare niente
quindi non potevo più vivere di quelle
emozioni forti che avevo vissuto fino a
quel momento le vittorie i brividi che
provavo quando ero sul gradino più alto
del podio pasta era finito tutto quanto
mi diedero un anno per recuperare a
camminare come prima
questo significava carriera finita non
ci volevo stare
e qui c'era un due virus ita una di
queste era dimezzare i tempi del
recupero con il doping
io invece scelto un'altra strada
io ho scelto un muro bianco perché
l'unica cosa che potevo fare in quei
mesi era pedalare su una cyclette
di fronte a un muro bianco io ho scelto
quel muro perché dietro quel muro c'era
la mia vetta dietro quel muro c'erano i
miei sogni
su quel muro ha scritto i miei valori
su quel muro c'era la mia fatica su quel
muro c'era me stessa e io ho pedalato
per ore e ore per risentire i miei
muscoli per risentire i miei brividi per
risentire le mie gambe e per risentire i
battiti del mio cuore del mio cuore
esplodere insieme a me hanno pedalato
per tutte quelle ore
fisioterapisti hanno pedalato gli
allenatori la mia famiglia
tutti tutte le persone che mi volevano
bene e io sono stata fortunata perchè ce
l'ho fatta a dimezzare i tempi con solo
ed esclusivamente la forza di volontà e
il lavoro sono riuscite a riconquistarsi
il posto per andare ai campionati del
mondo ce l'avevo fatta
ho lavorato molto per arrivare a quel
campionato del mondo e c'era riuscita
nella corsa per questo mondiale sono
inciampata perché a volte dalla foga non
vedevo più il mio obiettivo la mia vetta
però sono sempre risalita mi sono
rialzata e ho detto dai silvia che ce la
facciamo
è venuto il giorno della gara questo
questa giornata particolare e sono
entrata in pista carica di emozioni e di
speranze perché ci avevo messo tanta
tanta passione tanta grinta in quegli
allenamenti e mentre facevo il mio disco
sono inciampata ho fatto un salto e sono
caduta e ho perso
ho perso io sul muro bianco volevo
scrivere la parola vittoria
e invece ci dovevo scrivere la parola
sconfitta era una sconfitta che brucia
va tantissimo bruciava più del fuoco e
sapete perché bruciava così tanto perché
io ho un talento e non l'ho usato perché
io non sono riuscita a dare il massimo
di me stessa cosa che avevo sempre fatto
e mi rodeva ero arrabbiata tanto
arrabbiata perché non c'era riuscita
perché signori miei è dura non vincere è
dura quando sei quasi un po abituato
grazie al lavoro che hai svolto che hai
fatto a vincere ea dura perché tutte le
persone venivano lì da mary somma dai
silvi è andata bene comunque un secondo
posto secondo i mondiali insomma
vicecampionessa del mondo dopo un anno
terribile che hai passato appunto perché
ho passato un anno terribile e mi sono
veramente impegnata al massimo ho dato
tutta me stessa io ho perso un
pezzettino anche di me stessa
in quell'anno
perché sono arrivata nel momento di dare
il tutto per tutto e io non l'ho dato e
ho perso e in quel momento noi atleti
nei momenti un po di sconforto
abbiamo due strade una dove ripartì da
zero e ricominci tutto è una molto molto
semplice e facile una discesa che quella
discesa si trasforma in salita e una
corsa verso la vittoria che ti porta poi
a vincere è quella quella discesa si
chiama doping il doping il doping è
facile e veloce è dietro l'angolo è a
portata di mano ci metti un secondo a
cadere in tentazione
il doping è un gigante dai piedi
d'argilla che si frantuma in poco tempo
quando scegli di prendere quella
scorciatoia li tradisci prima di tutto
te stesso tradisci il lavoro che hai
fatto finora tradisci le persone che
hanno pedalato insieme a te fino a quel
momento tradisci lo sport
e i valori che lo sport in car ma è
soprattutto una vittoria con il doping
non ha valore perché prima o poi farà i
conti con te stesso perché prima o poi
ti guarderà i allo specchio e capirai
che anche se hai vinto se una brutta
persona sei davvero una brutta persona
perché quando guarderei le persone che
verranno complimentarti con te e
soprattutto dei giovani atleti e tu li
guardi in faccia cosa gli dici che vinto
grazie al doping che persona ti senti
che persona sei
e allora io in quel momento
ho deciso che quella scorciatoia anche
se facile se veloce se era così semplice
dire un sì cadere in tentazione non era
per me io volevo una bella via difficile
e tortuosa ma non perché sono masochista
perché mi piace la fatica perché come
dice car lewis c'è solo un modo per
allenarsi è quello giusto
e c'è solo un modo per vincere è quello
giusto
e allora da lì bisogna capire che
l'unica ricetta per andare a vincere è
lavoro lavoro lavoro
allora io dal giorno stesso in cui ho
perso ho lavorato giorno dopo giorno con
il mio allenatore 7 giorni su 7 2 volte
al giorno eravamo sulla media di 5 6 ore
al giorno non esistevano ferie non mi
interessavano non c'erano giorni di
riposo non mi interessavano io avevo un
obiettivo è quello obiettivo era
riprendermi ciò che era mio e volevo
dare il massimo e volevo far vedere a
tutti che non ero la campionessa finita
che non mi ero persa che non ero vecchia
che potevo dimostrare ancora tanto
e fu così che il 18 settembre 2015
ho vinto il mio undicesimo titolo del
mondo
ed ecco qui questa è la foto di una
vittoria questo è il mio allenatore
questa foto però dire che aveva fatto
della vittoria è un po riduttivo
questa quella foto della felicità perché
la felicità non ha sfumature non a
macchie una foto così se ti do p non la
fai
ma non ti viene neanche in questa foto
c'è tutta la fatica e la soddisfazione
di aver vinto un qualcosa solo con le
mie forze perché è l'unico modo per
arrivare ai tuoi obiettivi
la passione
il credere in quello che fai
i valori il sacrificio la fatica sono le
uniche cose
gli unici ingredienti che possono
sconfiggere il doping questo gigante dai
piedi di argilla e soprattutto la mia
ricetta è rispetto di una di una foto
che ho di una bambina nel
nell'armadietto del mio spogliatoio quel
ritratto sono io da bambina la prima
volta che ho messo i pattini con un
sorriso da orecchio a orecchio
io non mi sono dopato per non tradire
quella bambina lì grazie
[Applauso]